on est tous parfois témoins dans
l'entourage de quelqu'un qui agit d'une
manière un peu surprenante
ça peut être un comportement en public
une réaction celle où dans une situation
particulière ça peut être une phrase
prononcée au mauvais moment
peu importe et à ce moment là on se dit
mais comment ça se fait qu'il ou elle ne
se rend pas compte que ça ne se fait pas
on est d'autant plus surpris si la
plupart du temps cette même personne se
comportent d'une manière qui nous semble
tout à fait logique à la limite
quelqu'un qui agit toujours de manière
étrange on finit à tort ou à raison par
ne plus être surpris mais quelqu'un qui
semble partager avec nous ce qu'on
pourrait appeler à un sens commun ça
fait bizarre
bien sûr ce qui serait vraiment utile de
garder à l'esprit c'est que cela nous
arrive à nous aussi on disait mais
comment ça se fait qu'il ou elle ne se
rend pas compte que ça ne se fait pas et
bien c'est pareil pour nous parfois
quand on est à côté de la plaque quand
on dit un truc déplacer quand on est
maladroit voire désagréable
il arrive qu'on ne s'en rendent pas
compte je crois que notre inconscient
cherche à se rassurer et qu'il est
rassurant de penser que le fou c'est
l'autre donc on occulte nos propres
sortie de piste mais personne n'est 100%
du site 100% du temps sûrement qu'on ne
se rend compte que dans les cas les plus
évidents mais que cela arrive
constamment à des degrés divers
cette copine qu'on trouve normal elle a
aussi des réactions étranges mais
peut-être qu'elle passe sous le radar
parce qu'on se focalise sur cet autre
pote qui paraît toujours un peu perché
et je crois que pour ce qui est de notre
propre comportement
à moins de faire un travail conscient
dessus il nous est très difficile de le
considérer avec recul
si je fais vraiment attention et j ai
vraiment réfléchi j'ai bien l'impression
que je ne connais pas une seule personne
dont le comportement global
m'apparaîtrait comme logique du point de
vue de ce que j'ai cru comprendre de la
réalité il ya toujours une réaction par
ci un choix de vie par là qui semblent
révéler que cette personne dont je me
sens peut-être très proche par ailleurs
ne conçoit pas du tout l'existence de la
même manière que moi quand je me
concentre sur cette idée ça attise
sérieusement ce sentiment de solitude
existentielle dont je parlais ici parce
qu'elles répondent à d'autres lois à
d'autres systèmes de valeurs ou à
d'autres croyances j'ai l'impression que
ces personnes ne vivent pas sur la même
planète que moi mais ce qu'il faut
ajouter dans la foulée c'est que moi non
plus en fait je ne vis pas sur ma propre
planète
moi même je mène une existence qui ne
s'accorde pas à ma compréhension du
monde jeux
dire qu'il ya un décalage très claire
entre ce que je crois consciemment et la
manière dont je me comporte spontanément
j'ai beau ne pas croire au libre arbitre
je continue de me sentir responsable de
mes décisions exactement comme si
j'étais libre
j'ai beau penser que la réalité est une
construction mentale
je continue de vivre mon rapport au réel
comme steam était donné comme si j'avais
accès à quelque chose de stable et
transcendant il y a longtemps dans un
carnet après avoir ressenti ça un peu
intensément
j'avais écrit une petite pirouette qui
voulait résumer ce sentiment être faux
ce n'est pas être différent les autres
c'est être différent de soi même ça ne
prêtant bien sûr pas décrire un état de
pathologie mentale précis mais plutôt ce
sentiment de n'être pas adaptée à la
réalité la plus élémentaire
sylvia leur demande est venue de berne
commence ainsi ma vie ne ressemble pas à
ma vie et je trouve que ça exprime
parfaitement cette sensation étrange
je crois que je vais être démuni encore
un petit moment devant cette évidence
déstabilisante
il ya un hiatus entre moi et moi même
mais je trouve fascinant le travail qui
consiste à le combler